here now with more Fox News contributor
Jonathan Turley you know I I just a
simple question Jonathan you're a
fair-minded guy do you believe that the
investigations into Hillary Clinton when
you look into her servers deleted emails
the the dirty dossier uh then of course
the FBI's handling of that dossier and
using it without verifying it and then
of course the bidens I mean hunter
himself implicates his father all over
the place and then we have photographs
that Joe approved that Joe lied about
knowing Hunters Associates or anything
about the businesses so my question is
do we have equal justice under the law
in those three examples
well I think the record is clear that
there's been political bias at the FBI
the FBI itself has recognized that they
have removed key officials uh like Peter
strzok and others who showed incredible
bias uh in their emails and in some
cases in their actions I so I think
there's reason to be concerned it's not
a conspiracy theory the department
itself has has moved on these issues
what's really disturbing about the
hunter Biden matter is that this was
similar to what we saw with when Houdini
made his elephant Jenny disappear every
night on the stage well she really
didn't disappear she never lost left the
stage but Houdini knew that the audience
wanted her to disappear and the bidens
have been brilliant in the in handling
this Scandal they knew the media wanted
this Scandal to disappear and they gave
them room for that illusion now they're
running out of of time and they're
running out of space because the house
is going to launch this investigation
and I think that what we're going to see
is going to be disturbing you know the
fact is that the president has been
contradicted repeatedly it does appear
that his repeated denials that he never
spoke to his son about his business
deals is false I mean we have an actual
recording of him calling his son to say
that he wanted to talk to him about the
media investigation into his business
deals we have an individual who had said
under oath that he met twice with Joe
Biden to talk about the foreign dealings
with his son and his family so at a
minimum what we have is the appearance
of a multi-million dollar influence
peddling scheme involving the Biden
family but also the president of the
United States and yet Merrick Garland
has refused to appoint a special counsel
I don't question the appointment of a
special Counsel on the Trump issue he is
a presidential candidate that's within
the strike zone one can defend that but
you can't defend it if you're not
appointing a special counsel in my view
and the hunter Biden matter that
involves the city president of the
United States the and and Congressman
Comer said this is an investigation of
Joe Biden and the deeper issue here is
you have Hunter and the family making
millions of dollars Hunter has no
experience at all and Joe we now could
connect to Hunter we can connect them
financially now and the question is
bigger in other words is the reason that
we he canceled the Keystone XL pipeline
but gave a waiver to the Nordstrom 2
pipeline is that because of the money
that the bidens made from Russia or is
he compromised with China in other words
do we have a president potentially
compromised with foreign Nations and
adversarial countries
well I think that's the reason we need
to have finally this investigation the
Democrats blocked the investigation
earlier in Congress of these
transactions you know foreign countries
know about these transactions they know
about a lot of these issues it's the
American people that need to know
exactly what the scope of this is and
that includes these transfers there's a
lot of information that will come with
that information and the American people
will now be able to see it but the the
key here is not just that it's a matter
of being compromised but whether the
president has knowingly and repeatedly
lied to the American people they have a
right to know I think the bigger danger
though the White House would is if they
paid to play
he sold out his office that would be an
impeachable offense if that is a great
danger yes all right Jonathan Turley
always love having you thank you hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else